Podemos decir muchas cosas malas de Rusia,
pero tienen una buenísima que hay que reconocerle.
Si la regla de oro de cualquier casino es
“la banca siempre gana”, en el juego de
la energía la que siempre gana es Rusia.
Es el país más grande del mundo, con mucha
diferencia y, además, su territorio está
repleto de recursos naturales, lo que le da
una ventaja competitiva enorme.
Pensad sin ir más lejos en la cuarta economía
del mundo, en Alemania.
Mucho Volkswagen y mucho Siemens, pero durante
décadas Alemania ha dependido del gas ruso
para tener energía abundante y barata.
Como bien sabéis, todo esto saltó por los
aires con la invasión rusa de Ucrania.
Y claro, ha costado mucho encontrar alternativas.
Uno de los mayores problemas es la resistencia
de Alemania a utilizar la energía nuclear.
El pasado mes de abril apagaron sus 3 últimas
centrales nucleares.
Y claro, hay muchos expertos que subrayan
que eso es un error, que la nuclear podría
ser una alternativa al gas natural y la forma
de evitar por completo la dependencia de Rusia.
Pero esperad un momento, amigos, porque estamos
hablando de energía.
Y en este juego, ya sabéis, Rusia siempre
gana.
Con 37, Rusia no solo es el cuarto país del
mundo que tiene más reactores nucleares.
Es que también domina el mercado del combustible
nuclear.
Y es que veréis, aunque sus minas de uranio
apenas suponen el 5% de la producción de
todo el planeta, la cuota mundial de Rosatom
en el proceso de conversión del uranio se
eleva al 27% y se dispara hasta el 46% si
hablamos de capacidad dee enriquecimiento
de uranio.
Esto explica, tal y como os contamos aquí
en VisualPolitik el pasado mes de febrero,
por qué Occidente no impone sanciones a la
corporación estatal rusa de energía atómica.
Ahora bien, de igual forma que el GNL ha ofrecido
la mayor alternativa al gas ruso, con el combustible
nuclear hay otra alternativa que es Francia:
un país que tiene una gran tradición nuclear
y que podría ser una opción importante a
considerar por Occidente si lo que se busca
es disminuir la dependencia de Rusia.
En París tienen clara su estrategia.
Quieren hacerlo.
Pero tienen algunos escollos que resolver.
El principal es que el sector nuclear francés
lleva 15 años viviendo una crisis permanente.
Cuando apaga un fuego, enseguida se le origina
otro.
Y el último ha sido en un lugar tan alejado
como inesperado.
(Golpe de Estado en Níger genera preocupaciones
sobre la dependencia del uranio de Francia
y la Unión Europea.
Politico)
Níger era la última democracia del Sahel.
El presidente Bazoum era considerado por Francia
como un aliado importante para combatir el
auge del yihadismo en la región.
Ahora todo indica que las cosas podrían cambiar
por completo con la nueva junta militar de
Níger.
Los militares reprochan constantemente a Francia
sus abusos como antigua metrópoli y la acusan,
además, de entrometerse en sus asuntos internos.
Así que la pregunta es: ¿qué tiene que
ver lo que está pasando en Níger con la
estrategia francesa para dominar el mercado
del combustible nuclear?
¿En qué consiste esta estrategia?
¿Va a seguir Occidente comprando uranio enriquecido
a Rusia?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas.
Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1(EL URANIO DE LAS COLONIAS)
Hace 50 años se produjo la famosa crisis
del petróleo.
El precio del zumo de dinosaurio se multiplicó
por 4 después de que los países árabes
decidieran reducir su producción.
En ese momento, la mayor parte de la electricidad
de Francia, un país sin campos petrolíferos
propios, era generada por centrales de fuel
frente al 5% que aportaba la primera generación
de reactores nucleares.
Amigos, esta crisis fue clave para que se
activara el plan Messmer.
Pierre Messmer, el primer mi nistro del presidente
Pompidou, presentó en 1974 el plan con el
que Francia acabaría con su total dependencia
energética del petróleo extranjero.
Su objetivo era ni más ni menos que construir
decenas de reactores nucleares.
Lo único que necesitaba era uranio para su
combustible nuclear.
Y la Comisión francesa para la Energía Atómica
ya sabía dónde encontrarlo:
Somair y Cominak han sido durante décadas
dos de las mayores minas de uranio del mundo.
Francia descubrió uranio en Níger en 1957.
Por eso, cuando en 1960 este país africano
obtuvo su independencia, París se aseguró
de m antener un acceso prioritario a los recursos
naturales de Níger mediante un tratado.
De esta forma, la explotación a gran escala
de estas minas de uranio arrancó entre finales
de los años 60 y la década de los 70.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Allí Francia pudo desplegar todas las malas
prácticas que ya había experimentado en
Gabón.
(Francia comenzó a operar en 1960 la mina
de uranio de Mounana en Gabón.
A finales de los 60 las mediciones registraron
altos niveles de radiación gamma y alfa entre
los trabajadores mineros.
Adoptar los protocolos de protección contra
la radiación utilizados en Francia requería
de costosas inversiones y los franceses no
estaban por la labor.
Fue mucho más rentable la solución adoptada:
triplicar los umbrales a partir de los cuales
la exposición a la radiación se consideraba
peligrosa para la salud humana.)
Esta es una de las ventajas que tenían las
minas de las antiguas colonias para Francia.
Sus costes eran mucho más reducidos porque
ni la seguridad ni los salarios de los mineros
eran iguales que en otros países.
Y ahora seguro que alguno estará pensando:
bueno, si la explotación del uranio ha contaminado
un montón, al menos habrá dejado para Níger
un beneficio económico.
Pues no.
Los acuerdos de explotación eran abusivamente
ventajosos para Francia.
Durante muchas décadas las empresas mineras
francesas solo pagaron a Níger el 5,5% de
sus ingresos en impuestos.
En Canadá y en Kazajistán, donde la actual
Orano produce uranio desde finales de los
90, las tasas de regalías son del 13% y del
18,5% respectivamente.
Esto ha provocado disparidades como las que
podéis ver en este gráfico entre la cantidad
de uranio producido y los ingresos que recibe
cada país a cambio.
En 2014 se negoció un nuevo acuerdo entre
Níger y Orano, entonces llamada Areva.
La tasa de regalías se elevó del 5,5% a
una cifra en torno al 12%, siempre que se
dieran ciertas condiciones de rentabilidad
y precio del uranio.
Vamos, que se mejoraron ligeramente las condiciones,
pero Francia ha seguido jugando en Níger
con cierta ventaja respecto al mercado internacional.
Si a esto le añadimos que Níger es uno de
los países más pobres del mundo, seguramente
podemos hablar de un caso más de la maldición
de los recursos.
Así lo llaman los economistas cuando se refieren
a un Estado que no se beneficia financieramente
de la venta de sus recursos.
Ahora bien, no hay mayor maldición que la
de la corrupción de sus dirigentes.
En 1974 el teniente coronel Seyni Kountché
dio un golpe de Estado.
Presidente hasta 1987, Kountché reclamó
recibir directamente parte de la producción
de óxido de uranio en un porcentaje igual
al de la participación del Estado de Níger
en las filiales nigerinas de las empresas
mineras francesas.
Un porcentaje superior al 30%.
De esta forma, Kountché quería vender el
uranio por su cuenta en el mercado internacional.
Las intenciones atómicas de sus clientes
no eran precisamente pacíficas: el Irak de
Saddam Hussein, la Libia de Gaddafi, Pakistán…
A Kountché se le atribuye la frase: “Venderemos
uranio incluso al diablo si es necesario”.
Ahora ya sé lo que estáis pensando.
Dado que la junta militar que ha tomado el
poder en Níger tiene ganas de revancha frente
a Francia, seguro que rompen los acuerdos
de explotación de sus minas, expulsan a Orano
del pa ís y Francia pierde todo el uranio
de Níger.
Y claro, teniendo en cuenta que las centrales
nucleares generan en torno al 70% de la electricidad
de Francia, si de repente los militares de
Níger cortan el suministro de uranio, seguro
que la producción energética de Francia
tiembla.
¿Verdad?
Pues no.
A diferencia de Alemania con el gas ruso,
esta vez Francia ha hecho sus deberes y los
ha hecho muy bien.
(Francia ha sabido diversificar su suministro
de uranio.
Según los datos de los últimos 10 años,
las 88.200 toneladas de uranio natural importadas
por Francia procedieron principalmente de
tres países: Kazajistán (27%), Níger (20%)
y Uzbekistán (19%).
También destacan las importaciones de Australia
y Namibia, con un 14% en cada caso.
En cuanto a los datos anuales, el uranio de
Níger nunca supuso más de un 35% de las
importaciones francesas en un mismo ejercicio.)
Estos datos son similares a los de Orano.
En 2010, las minas de Níger proporcionaban
dos tercios de su producción mundial.
Sin embargo, ahora Níger aporta menos de
un tercio después de que cerrara en 2021
la mina de Cominak.
Todo esto quiere decir que el uranio de Níger,
antaño decisivo, tiene ahora una importancia
relativa para el sistema energético francés,
pues apenas supone un 20% del uranio que importan.
Comparad eso con el 60% que suponía el gas
ruso para Alemania o incluso el 90% que suponía
para países de Europa del Este como la República
Checa.
En otras palabras, que si Níger corta el
grifo del uranio, Francia podría reemplazarlo
fácilmente con importaciones de otros países.
Ahora bien, eso no quiere decir que la interrupción
no tuviera ningún efecto.
Sería un contratiempo para su estrategia
de ser una alternativa a Rusia en el mercado
del combustible nuclear.
¿De qué estoy hablando?
Atentos.
T2(UN MERCADO DOMINADO POR RUSIA)
Igual que las centrales de ciclo combinado
utilizan gas natural como combustible para
generar electricidad, las centrales nucleares
necesitan su propio combustible.
El proceso más utilizado en las plantas atómicas
para generar energía es la fisión nuclear.
Para ello necesitan un elemento que sea fisible.
Aquí es donde entra en juego el uranio.
Ahora bien, igual que el petróleo lo tienes
que refinar para obtener combustibles como
la gasolina o el gasóleo, el uranio lo tienes
que enriquecer para poder utilizarlo como
combustible en las centrales nucleares.
El proceso es el mismo que el utilizado para
desarrollar bombas atómicas.
Lo que cambia es el nivel de enriquecimiento
que se necesita.
Mirad.
(El uranio natural, tal como se extrae de
las minas, está compuesto en un 99,3% por
isótopos de uranio 238, no fisibles.
La parte fisible, los isótopos de uranio
235, solo suponen el 0,7%.
Enriquecido a entre un 3% y un 5%, este uranio
sirve como combustible nuclear para las centrales
que generan electricidad.
Hasta el 20%, el uranio enriquecido sirve
para producir isótopos médicos, utilizados
especialmente en el diagnóstico de algunos
cánceres.
Finalmente, para fabricar una bomba, el enriquecimiento
debe llevarse hasta el 90%.
)
Aquí está la clave que ha hecho que el mercado
internacional del combustible nuclear esté
dominado por Rusia.
Tradicionalmente, el uranio se ha enriquecido
a través de dos métodos.
Occidente se inclinó por el más sencillo:
la difusión gaseosa.
Sin embargo, amigos, este método más sencillo
resultaba carísimo, ya que requiere de mucha
energía para enriquecer el uranio.
¿De cuánta energía estamos hablando?
Pues para que os hagais una idea, la planta
de enriquecimiento que abrió Francia a finales
de los años 70 consumía 15 teravatios/hora
al año, la misma cantidad de electricidad
que se utilizaría actualmente para el alumbrado
público de París durante un siglo.
(Durante las 3 décadas que estuvo en funcionamiento,
la planta de enriquecimiento de uranio Georges
Besse fue el mayor consumidor de electricidad
de Francia; devoraba alrededor del 4% de toda
la producción eléctrica del país galo.
De hecho, en el apogeo de la Guerra Fría,
alrededor del 7% de la generación total de
electricidad de Estados Unidos se dedicó
al enriquecimiento de uranio, tanto para fines
militares como civiles.)
La difusión gaseosa era el método utilizado
por Occidente.
Ahora bien, ¿qué hacían al otro lado del
telón de acero?
Pues, amigos, el programa nuclear soviético
es conocido por todos.
Tanto a nivel de armamento como de energía
atómica.
La URSS puso en marcha una treintena de reactores.
En cuanto al enriquecimiento de uranio, la
Unión Soviética optó por una técnica más
compleja: la centrifugación.
Eso sí, es un método que consume 50 veces
menos de energía que la difusión gaseosa.
Esto explica a día de hoy, en pleno 2023,
noticias como esta:
Putin sigue vendiendo a Estados Unidos casi
mil millones de dólares en combustible nuclear.
Newsweek)
Cuando cayó la Unión Soviética en 1991,
Estados Unidos y la nueva Rusia acordaron
lo que se conoce popularmente como el “programa
de megatones a megavatios".
El uranio altamente enriquecido de las antiguas
ojivas nucleares soviéticas se transformó
en uranio poco enriquecido y se envió a Estados
Unidos para usarlo en plantas civiles.
Asimismo, dada la diferencia de costes, las
compañías eléctricas occidentales se lanzaron
a adquirir uranio enriquecido ruso.
Se beneficiaban así de la tecnología más
competitiva en costes de la época soviética,
el problema es que al mismo tiempo llevaron
a la ruina a las instalaciones de Occidente
que aún utilizaban la difusión gaseosa.
Pero claro, en aquellos felices años 90,
lo único que corría peligro de acabarse
con Boris Yeltsin eran nuestras reservas de
alcohol.
Así que Rusia logró de esta forma una posición
de dominio del mercado que ha beneficiado
enormemente a Rosatom, la corporación estatal
creada en 2007 por Vladímir Putin para ser
el gigante ruso en el mercado global de la
energía nuclear.
Un gigante que resulta absolutamente intocable
aún en las condiciones más adversas.
(Aumenta la presión sobre la Unión Europea
para que sancione a Rosatom en el próximo
paquete de sanciones a Rusia.
Euroactiv)
Ni Bruselas ni Washington se han atrevido
a sancionar el combustible nuclear de Rosatom.
Hace años que Estados Unidos dejó de enriquecer
uranio y aproximadamente un tercio del combustible
nuclear que utiliza actualmente se importa
de Rusia, el mayor productor del mundo y también
el más barato.
Y aún así la factura se eleva cada año
a casi 1.000 millones de dólares.
Así que, en plena guerra de Ucrania, con
sanciones sobre el petróleo, sobre el gas
natural y sobre miles de empresas y productos
de Rusia, lo ideal sería no depender del
Kremlin en cuanto al combustible nuclear.
¿Verdad?
Pues aquí es donde entra en juego la estrategia
de Francia.
T3(LA NUCLÉAIRE ÉPOQUE)
Amigos, si estáis viendo este vídeo desde
Alemania o España, quizás os sorprenda.
Pero la nuclear está de moda.
Actualmente, se están construyendo en el
mundo 59 reactores nucleares.
Está previsto que estas cifras aumenten en
otros 111 en los próximos años.
Además, hay planes para otros 321.
El 40% de estos reactores se sitúan en China.
Pero otras potencias como Rusia o India también
están apostando fuerte por la energía nuclear.
Incluso en Estados Unidos hay importantes
planes para relanzar esta industria.
Y esperad un momento, porque en Europa hay
países que no se quieren quedar atrás.
Francia ya anunció antes de la guerra de
Ucrania que construiría 6 nuevos reactores.
Pero es que al margen de Reino Unido, también
Polonia, Países Bajos, Eslovenia, Eslovaquia,
República Checa, Hungría, Bulgaria, Rumanía,
Estonia y Lituania cuentan con la nuclear
entre sus planes.
Y es posible que algún país más se sume
después del espaldarazo dado por la Unión
Europea a esta tecnología.
(El Parlamento de la Unión Europea apoya
etiquetar las inversiones en gas y energía
nuclear como verdes.
Reuters)
La transición energética y la lucha contra
el cambio climático van a exigir inversiones
en nuevas tecnologías.
También en todo aquello que suponga mantener
nuestra calidad de vida al mismo tiempo que
reducimos las emisiones de gases invernadero.
Es en este ámbito en el que Bruselas ha decidido
que las renovables y la nuclear tienen que
ir de la mano.
Además, los nuevos reactores modulares están
cambiando por completo la realidad de esta
industria: necesitan mucha menos inversión
y pueden construirse mucho más rápido
Por estos motivos, lo s países europeos están
dispuestos a dar una nueva oportunidad a la
energía atómica.
Planean construir nuevas centrales y, claro,
hará falta lo más importante: el combustible
nuclear.
Hará falta aumentar la producción de uranio
en las minas, sí, pero también aumentar
la capacidad para procesar ese uranio, convertirlo
y enriquecerlo.
Y justo aquí es donde Francia quiere tener
un papel protagonista.
Ya está trabajando en ello, tal y como reflejan
noticias como esta:
(Francia sopesa una nueva planta de uranio
para reducir la dependencia de Occidente de
Rusia.
Bloomberg)
Según un portavoz de Orano, la compañía
estatal francesa valora dos opciones: por
un lado, construir una planta de enriquecimiento
de uranio en Estados Unidos; por otro, una
opción que sería la más rápida y probable:
ampliar un 50% la capacidad de su moderna
planta Georges Besse II, operativa desde 2011
y que ya enriquece uranio mediante la técnica
de la centrifugación.
El uranio enriquecido se mide en SWU, unidades
de trabajo separativo.
Pues bien, en su planta Georges Besse II,
Francia enriquece 7,5 millones de SWU al año.
Aumentarlo un 50% supondría elevar su capacidad
hasta los 11 millones mientras que las centrales
nucleares francesas necesitan actualmente
alrededor de 6,5 millones.
Esto se corresponde con las alrededor de 8.000
toneladas de uranio natural que Francia necesita
para sus centrales nucleares.
Si piensa producir 11 millones de SWU, necesitará
importar cada año más de 13.000 toneladas
de uranio.
Y aquí es donde Níger podría generar un
problema para Francia.
Como os decía antes, su sistema energético
puede permitirse el lujo de prescindir de
las casi 2.000 toneladas que importa todos
los años de Níger.
Encontraría otros proveedores.
Pero Francia sí que necesita ese uranio para
su estrategia de convertirse en un exportador
importante de combustible nuclear y en una
alternativa real al dominio ruso.
En cualquier caso, que nadie dude de que Macron
está trabajando en esta dirección.
Y eso explica noticias como esta:
(El uranio de Mongolia interesa a Francia.
LeMonde)
Macron y su ministra de Exteriores han visitado
Mongolia en los últimos meses.
Allí han mostrado interés en realizar inversiones
por valor de unos 1.000 millones de euros
para hacerse con el uranio de Mongolia así
como de otros metales como el litio.
Claro, en Ulán Bator no se han visto en otra
y han recibido a Macron con los brazos abiertos.
Incluso dicen que Francia es el tercer vecino
de Mongolia, ese país gigante emparedado
como un sándwich entre Rusia y China.
En esta línea se espera que se produzca un
acuerdo importante muy pronto.
Por supuesto, eso no quita para que de momento
Francia tenga un dolor de cabeza importante
con Níger.
No perdáis de vista que la potencia que se
está haciendo fuerte en el Sahel es Rusia,
que podría encontrarse de repelnte en Níger
con un nuevo suministrador de uranio.
Algo que sin duda contribuiría a consolidar
aún más su posición de dominio sobre el
mercado del combustible nuclear.
Y esto significa que si el mundo sigue apostando
por la energía atómica, todos, incluido
Occidente, aumentaremos la dependencia de
Rusia, incrementando así el poder de Putin
y del Kremlin.
Esa al menos parece ser la idea de Moscú.
Pero, ahora, amigos, la pregunta es para todos
vosotros:
¿Creéis que Francia tendrá éxito en su
estrategia?
¿O en el juego de la energía siempre ganará
Rusia?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.